[Music]
hey there were behind the scenes of the
new Deadpool to music video starring
Celine Dion's hologram I don't know why
they didn't just send the real Celine
well I dunno play restraining what is
there anyway I'm a little nervous today
we haven't done any dancing since I
moved out from Canada in 98 and that was
between two dumpsters between going
goodbye so I need to really up my game
here I had five bones from my body
removed including my collarbones
seven inches to spine it's all just be a
little bit of fluid you look good
are there real the boobs yeah it a good
- cup but mine too
she thinks I'm spider-man love to hear
anyway
[Music]
you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care auditor stronk eyes
beautiful girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching a
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you missed me read
what in the ass my name is cable here
for the kid what the kid movie guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be he needs you
lot smarter than I look
I let cable kill this kid but I can't do
this alone
we're gonna form a super duper group
that's what we're gonna be
forward-thinking gender neutral you will
be known as x-force you're absolutely
right now cue the music
tell me they got that in slow motion
doing the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right sometimes
fight dirty
that is why the man bun is just a
millennial mullet Oh
oh god I wish I finished college it
lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it
[Music]
you